What happens with the postmodernist as
they say,
oh,
there's an infinite number of
interpretations,
and then the human part of them goes,
okay,
well what am I supposed to do next?
Then since there's an infinite number of
choices and the postmodernist says,
well,
my theory can't account for that,
and then they say,
well,
back to Marxism,
and so that's why I think there's this
unholy alliance between the
postmodernists and the Neo Marxists
because postmodernism is a is a dead end
from the perspective of applicable
wisdom.
It leaves you bereft and nihilistic and
that's not good because people can't
exist without a purpose and so they
sneak the Marxism through the back door
and and jump into this power landscape
for the reasons that we discussed
earlier.
So I really think that it's because of
an infinite number of possibilities
interpretating things because I've
always felt that it was really just a
response to capitalism.
The capitalism is a very negative aspect
of our culture and society and that
there's gotta be some sort of an
alternative.
Marxism is a clearly defined alternative
that other people have subscribed to in
the past.
You could point to it,
it's a structure that's already are
already set up and it's romanticized and
I think they adopted for that reason
because it has a socialist aspects
attached to it and they looked at
socialism as some sort of a thing that a
regards equality and uh,
you know,
some sort of an egalitarian.
Well,
okay,
so we'd have to take two things apart.
We'd have to take Marxism slash neo,
Marxist,
Marxism and postmodernism apart.
So we could do that historically.
And I would say that although there is a
reason for postmodernism,
which is the reason we just discussed,
that the landscape,
the infinite landscape of interpretation
problem,
it's a real problem.
If you look at it historically,
postmodernism actually grew out of
Marxism.
And so what,
what,
what happened is that the Marxists laid
out their,
their,
their theory about the human social
environment being composed of a power
struggle between the privileged and the
underprivileged,
right?
The rich and the poor.
And in its initial phases.
And that's a story that's partially true
and it's got a lot of motive power.
Like the motive power is the romantic
motive power that you just described.
I get to be on this side of the
oppressed.
I get to be a war.
You're for what's right.
There's the resentment element,
which is that son of a bitch has more
than me,
so let's cut them off at the knees,
which manifested itself brutally in the
Soviet Union and then there's the
ideological totality issue which gives
people a sense of security that took a
vicious hit by by the late 19 sixties
because the murderousness of Marxism had
been clearly laid out as a doctrine and
that opened the door to this move by by
mostly French intellectuals to to
develop the postmodern philosophy which
has these advantages which we described,
but also to use that as a screening
tactic for allowing Marxism to transform
into identity politics and so like.
It's hard to disentangle all the
motivations that are going on in there,
but there's something about it that's
that's truly intellectually
pathological.
Because you don't get to be a
postmodernist and a Marxist.
You actually technically cannot be both
of those things at the same time.
And the fact that most people are both
of those things at the same time raises
the specter of just exactly what their
motivation is.
And then I would say it's this
resentment driven anti capitalism,
and there's reasons to criticize
capitalism obviously,
but it's this underground resentment
driven anti-capitalism that I think is
one of the fundamental motivators.